luis garcia
how about the 35 strikeout rate in the
last three games
fourth highest in the american league
behind cease
coal and glass now that is absolutely
getting it done ground ball two big hops
for yuliy guriel
yuli feeling frisky early doesn't need
his pitcher's help because he takes it
to the bag himself there's one away nick
solac the batter
this fastball is swung on and lifted
high in the air to left field deep in
that little kind of odd area and diaz
can't come up with it not sure where the
ball is now he finds it nick solak
around second he goes to third slides in
for a one-out triple there's a better
view right there he jumps
definitely could have come up with it
but it's just an awkward play as it is
nate lowe's down on the count one two
four twelve batting average with runners
in scoring position
and he does lift the fly ball to left
field this one is deep but
diaz is going to have some room and
he'll take a shot at solace but he'll
have absolutely no chance of getting him
as select slides in ahead of the throw
so the rangers score one here in the top
of the first they lead it one nothing so
that brings up joey gallo 206 six home
runs 18 rbis for the rangers right
fielder here comes that full count pitch
fastball swung on and lined into right
field for a base hit and joey gallo
beats the shift for a two out single now
david dahl stands in
and a pop-up should be playable bregman
into foul territory
puts it away for the final out of the
inning seven starts for dunning this
year era just under four continues to
just have
quality start after quality start altuve
with a lead-off walk a good start for
the astros down one-nothing and here is
oledmi's diaz kick in the pitch
and that's a ground ball through the
right side a base hit altuve goes to
second and diaz is a board with a first
pitch single here's alex bregman
to one pitch up the middle base hit out
two bay scores diaz being waved around
he is gonna score astros will take a two
to one lead on the two rbi single by
alex bregman
runner at third for correa a one
breaking ball and that's drilled deep to
right back on it as gallow at the wall
he leads see you later
a two-run home run for carlos correa and
a 4-1 astros lead
dane dunning hadn't allowed a home run
since the first inning of his first
start of the year to beau buchet of
toronto
that was on
april 6.
he had thrown 32 and a third consecutive
innings without giving up a homer but
that streak just came to an end courtesy
of correa
straw steps in with his 220 batting
average it's a ground ball to isaiah
connor for aleppo over to nate lowe and
the inning is over but not before the
houston astros put up a four spot here's
isaiah connor falefa he's been one of
the hottest texas rangers one two swing
and a miss got on the chase a breaking
ball down and away gets on the side of
that one and spins it off the plate
connor falefa can't recognize and lay
off got willie calhoun to ground out his
first time up that's hit hard backhanded
by julie guriel he will flip it to luis
garcia covering
sharply hit by calhoun but he's a final
out of the inning so alex bregman steps
in with two outs now
this one grounded to the left side the
bonnies has it throws on the run and
bregman retired easily and so a nice
bounce back inning for dame dunning so
solace draws a lead off walk nate lowe
will be the batter sac fly his first
time bregman way off the bag at third
and there is the reason for the shift
altuve shovels to correa the return
throw in time for a double play
joey gallow the batter
swing and a miss got him with the high
fastball luis garcia strikes out joey
gallo to end the inning three strikeouts
for luis we head to the bottom of the
third 4-1 houston here's jordan alvarez
singled his first time up that ball is a
rope into center field yard on two for
two
hitting lasers so far today as he
singles to start the third inning pal
tucker singled in the first inning
hitting one against the shift one two
that is on the inside corner for strike
three perfectly located fastball and the
ending draws to a close luis garcia set
to face adolesce garcia who singled his
first time that ball popped high in the
air into shallow right center field
altuve calling tucker off but tucker is
calling altuve off and now fakes like
he's going to catch it there's one away
two out going on for isaiah connor
falefa ball hit hard to right field back
goes tucker still going back he jumps
and he makes the catch in front of the
wall flips the ball into the crowd kyle
tucker a nice playing right one two
three inning for garcia the fourth
inning miles straw leading things off
for the astros here comes the 2-2 from
dunning and there's a front door
breaking ball called strike three
beautiful work there from dane dunning
against miles strong so he is retired
for the second time runners move up to
second and third and here's alex bregman
and the 1-0 ground ball will hit firmly
to the left side but connor fluffa is
there throws the first in plenty of time
and bregman is retired anya struck out
swinging his first time up one of three
strikeouts for garcia swing and a miss
luis garcia gets
andy abanos for the second consecutive
time that's now four strikeouts so one
out and one on for willy calhoun swing
and a miss got him upstairs strikeout
number five for luis garcia two outs in
the inning low grounded into a double
play and also hit a sacrifice fly his
first time up
ground ball towards altuve jose is there
luis garcia 94 pitches five innings of
work leading four to one there are now
two outs in the inning garielle at third
tucker at first for straw that three two
once again and a fast ball down and in
lifted to right field lazily to joey
gallo who makes the catch and so a
shutout inning for colby top of the
sixth inning and the rangers got some
work to do as they trail the houston
astros by three they'll have a different
pitcher and some opportunities here as
dusty baker decides to go to his bullpen
yep bryan abreu back on the mountain
joey gala will be the first batter that
he faces and the one two and a little
slider is popped up into shallow center
field and that is going to get down for
a base hit and despite the fact that
joey gallows bat might have been
shredded there he'll take it so one out
and one on for david dahl
hit high and deep to center field straw
all the way back he's nearing the wall
he will jump up and make the catch
against the fence
all the way back into first base his
throw comes in but that is a nice play
by mile straw
against the wall in the outfield and
brian of bray you appreciate it bases
are loaded for jordon alvarez
and look at this breaking ball down and
away and on three pitches
colby allard strikes out jordan alvarez
excellent work by the left-hander
and fires and there's a high fly ball
short right field it's gallow over to
his right and he's got it one pitch and
hunter wood gets the job done
six innings complete it's still four to
one houston here's willie calhoun
batting with two outs and nobody on this
ball sent high in the air to center
field mile straw to his left brian abreu
a one two three seventh inning hurray on
base for the third time tonight here's
kyle tucker underwood delivers and
tucker crushes one deep to right going
back on it gallow at the wall looking up
see you later
a two-run home run for kyle tucker and
the astros lead grows to six to one
tucker with his ninth home run of the
year the rangers have two men on and
nobody out and joey gallo coming up here
joey gallo tears into a 97 mile an hour
fastball from stanic and it is gone line
shot home run on a no two pitch for joey
gallo
three run shot for him and the rangers
right back in this game
six to four seventh home run of the
season for joey gallo and rbis 19-20 and
21. brender's at the corners with one
out for andy ibanez who represents the
go-ahead run
this ball grounded to the left side
right to alex bregman over to jose
altuve for one throw is in the dirt
guriel cannot come up with it and so
david dowell will score and the rangers
are now within one villac will face a
pinch hitter chris davis will hit for
the catcher jonah hein
ball hit to center field playable for
miles straw calls off kyle tucker and
puts it away for the final out of the
inning rangers get four in the inning
it's a one-run game they're gonna need
the best of ryan presley who's been the
closer for the astros
six for six in those save opportunities
rangers are down to their final out got
him foul tip cut by maldonado
that's a season-high five-game winning
streak for the astros
they move to six games over 500 for the
first time this year and they have won
the first three games of this lone star
series against the rangers got tight a
little bit late plumber but a big win